welcome to uh ee 380 for
april 20th uh 2022.
uh my name is dennis allison i uh curate
the course and uh today i happen to be
the lecturer as well
uh and we're going to
try to explain why that's happened
um
i think we're in a
this is a difficult time for
everybody
um and
uh i've had
well i have
been doing the 380 course for quite a
long time i think
something like 40 plus years
um and
it's usually very easy
to
[Music]
find speakers who
are willing to come and talk in fact
we've had people fly halfway around the
world and spend a whole week traveling
so they could come and give a one-hour
talk here in the
you know
um
since the beginning of the pandemic
or maybe slightly before
that's really changed uh people uh
people are doing things
differently than they have that
and
um
i found that
people are
they're just not quite uh as aware of
what's going on
now this is the
commercial community and the
professional computing
computing community
as well and the research community as
well as
the student community that we
generally see undergraduate or graduate
master's level people who want to give
talks
mostly it's phd candidates and people
doing research
but
the
the thirst for
publicizing oneself on the
on the web and so forth partially has
gone away because
anybody can make a video
or uh it's also gone away because
uh people are trying to be more private
um
now as a as a curator
uh
my
mode of operation is to
to look at uh
at what's going on
pick an interesting topic
find out who knows about it
nearby and far away
talk to them over the internet
and maybe a year or two later uh
with a speaker to come and talk
and that's uh that's that's worked
pretty well
um of late
not so well
people don't answer they don't answer
their emails
in fact most people don't read their
emails
and of course we have twitter which is
right only
and no one ever reads their incoming
twitters do they
do anybody have that as an experience
you how many were used were that
even a better thing yeah okay
uh in any case i agree
it's um
well it there are for a messaging app
it's about
second to the bottom i think uh i think
linkedin has has won the uh
has won the bottom
bottom rank
um
on the other hand lincoln has better
access to addresses
uh if you need to to uh
probably the best way to do it is to uh
in any case
uh let's see where was i i was trying to
tell you about the uh
the lack of
excessive
people people don't put their addresses
on on the internet anymore they don't
use emails
they uh try to hide emails companies
don't have their physical address on the
on the internet nor do they sometimes
even put their web address on the
internet
it's um
it's sort of
as if they're trying to
hide out
and
when you're
looking to find what people are doing
and
you know not with
without any real malice want like to get
them to come and talk about it
um
it's hard to find
the people and get them to say yes to
the prophet
um
this has led to an occasional problem
for us or for me
in that um
the period of time that you can
book people into the into the uh
this particular course
requires a
substantial lead time
and finding a speaker late in the in the
time period
is extremely difficult
so
if you don't get
speakers lined up and they all don't
agree and no one changes their mind or
wants to change their schedule
uh or uh needs some special thing
uh
it goes very smoothly and as a result
half the time the quarter evolves into
chaos and we reorganize everything every
uh every few minutes at same time
um so what happens what happened this
time was that the planned speaker uh was
uh
called a way to do something more
important than this and
so uh he's unavailable and
finding uh other people
to step in was um
in this case
um
worked fine
in a sense though
uh in the sense that i got to think
about this and now i can come back and
do this
but so we have we have the the issue
are people going to be public
public
people
expressing their views
uh in public or are they wanting to hide
out and
just be very quiet and back to them
same thing is true about topics by the
way
there are topics that people will not
touch
and there are important topics that we
uh
that we uh manage to uh critically avoid
uh one of them being
i will go through several
uh one of them being uh vaccinations
uh it's uh
very difficult to
get in
be willing to talk about the coded
vaccines and whether
it's they're being applied or right and
what the
what the actual
numbers involved are and so forth
uh what it's
what this particular pandemic has has
trained me to do is to worry a great
deal about the accuracy of the
uh public health people and their
their willingness to uh
produce and
destroy
uh numbers that are not particularly uh
pleasant
um
but that's that's been that's a very
interesting thing i think it falls into
the same category as the names thing
uh there are lots of other areas that uh
uh things are
not quite right in my taste
we
[Music]
we have lots of people who are putting
out
false information of some sort
onto the internet
and
the most interesting of them
are uh remarkably credible they use long
latin and greek uh
rooted words which have
uh vaguely medical uh sounding
pronunciations
and uh create their own meaning
these terms where they take
standard things and
can vote
can
can
make them non
not what they really are but move their
scope into a different area and you know
produce a
uh
story credible to non-non-speakers
scientists
but uh
uh frightening and uh disturbing and
creating uh disruption i think
the anti-vaxx people are uh i think uh
very
uh very bad for
for the sciences because it really has
helped destroy
uh belief in science
in fact uh science is not uh fairly well
and i don't
i don't think
it's necessarily the science fault
science scientists tend to be very
very factual in their descriptions of
things
and they don't uh they don't really try
to sell their theories in general
and uh that that i think is uh
is is a failure but it it's it's it's
sort of part of the times
um
likewise we don't have anybody who's
willing to talk about the global warming
stuff
there's more people here at stanford i
think that do that than in most in most
areas
but the uh the global warming thing and
they
are um
you know we're uh we're toast or
literally toast
it's
it's not a good situ
it's not getting better it's getting
worse
and
relatively few people are willing to
look at it i mean how many of you
believe that global warming is that is
going to
have a major impact on your life for the
next 10 years
next five years
yeah okay so you think you have five
years
probably not true it's probably already
here
and um
it's uh it's it's only been a
topic of study and conversation and
concern
by the geophysicists for the last
45 years or so
and yet
now that people acknowledge at least
that it's a major problem has anything
been done substantively
to uh
to try to correct it
you
you
you wave your hand uh is it something
which uh you could uh uh
tell me what you know what it is uh i
mean
ah
it is related somewhat to global warming
yeah i i made i made one of the first
ones
the whole
um
project which uh funded by the air force
where we uh
we've made a hole in the iosphere
and it got as big as all the doors
uh literally we uh
uh it was quite quite interesting and it
only took a few pounds of uh
a uh sulfur hexafluoride
uh the um oh it inserted at the right
point which is several hundred
hundred miles uh
miles up
um but
the uh
the uh
chemicals which we're using now and
replace with the
the uh
uh fluorophore
fluorohydrocarbons
are um
not as bad
but they're not very good
and so we are still pumping out very
large enough quantities of stuff which
produces uh
destruction of the ozone layer in the
ionosphere
if you lived in australia or visit you
would see that
the
the
daily news it would have a uh
a sun block requirement as to how much
sunblock you should put on because they
sort of
keep track of that and the ozone layer
above
decided
when things are going to be critical
but that's that's another another thing
so
well they're
there you can continue on with uh with
other examples of places where
we have not really as a
collective community
uh managed to
get
any sort of action performed yes go
ahead
that's that's that's right and in fact
uh that's the the uh
uh the bitcoin
and blockchain ideas
are
not really
energy
conservative
and tremendous amounts of energy are
being used today
to uh to manage the bitcoin
and
probably a bad idea to to use it much at
all
and the reason of course is inherent
in
one of the goals of the of the uh
the bitcoin
idea
that is is you want
multiple places that you can
take a piece of information and stick it
on the timeline
and know that it occurred between point
a and point b
and you want to be able to uh to do that
from
any site you are and there are going to
be lots of people monitoring that
and so it all has to happen
in a fixed period of time
and
now you've just created what's pretty
much guaranteed to be a very difficult
problem to solve
now
the fact that most applications that use
bitcoin don't the fact that it's
distributed it has multiple application
points
is usually sort of ignored
but it it many of the things that people
use bitcoin for are
essentially a
could be
could be accomplished with a fairly
reliable set of
single entry file systems and
much much more energy efficient uh
there's a
cacm article
uh by maurice hurley
on uh
on
the
uh
bitcoin
blockchain and
what what needs to be done to fix it
and it's worth it's worth thinking about
how many of you read csm
how many read computers
uh wired
yeah occasionally why
okay
so that's that's that's interesting for
me because uh
uh i always found that the
the popular literatures
were pretty interesting and the
magazines like cacm were really really
uh helpful
cscm has been
well i would say dumbed out
uh that is because
the uh computing community has grown
very large
and most of the people don't have
a great deal of mathematics and in fact
not a great deal necessarily programming
capability
at this point
the
content of the cacm doesn't really step
into
anything that's really very complicated
you have to go to one of the other ecm
publications like the journal or
one of the sync publications to find
things that are
really
new and interesting
and solutions to problems which are hard
so and one of the things i've always
so any case
i i painted i'm i'm painting
a uh a picture of uh
uh how uh
how
strange things really are that is the a
lot of the protocols that we we
developed for maintaining science and
the uh
and the reputations of science as a
safe and uh
suitably
reliable source
have uh been
obligated
part of this part of this seems to be
um
due to the fact that
things are
kind of
difficult to understand
but i i don't think i don't think
there's a i don't think
science per se is necessarily hard to
understand what is hard to understand
is why uh people are
uh always trying to uh
uh
and when they present things in a
popular way they always try to provide
two points of view uh
the one and the other
so you get uh
situations like uh the uh
the earth is round or the earth is flat
and the people who believe it's flat get
the same amount of storage
presentation space
as the one purchase
for this right
uh that's
i think uh
[Music]
difficult if you're not really sure
whether the world was rounded flat
and because it tends to give you the
wrong the wrong idea
um
i think that's that's that's a big issue
uh the
the
fact the
world is
not
fixing some of their known problems is i
think a very very difficult thing and i
think that that means that
we probably ought to be out there trying
trying to change the way that the
world views
science and engineering and the world
the way the world views uh solving these
sorts of problems
uh maybe i'm an ie but i think that
that's that's important
in um
in california we have
going back to other sorts of problem
areas in california we have uh
massive forest fires
uh it happens in other parts of the
world as well
but we don't really
pull out all stops and try to
stop the forest
and minimize the amount of carbon
dioxide that gets generated
my sort of
i'm not really certain why
the government does not choose to
try to do something like that because it
will in the long run
help us
um we had a talk a couple years ago i
guess it's this year last year
um
[Music]
from uh uh david hankel wallace about uh
his uh his startup uh
blue aura on
well i can't remember i think it's blue
orange on origin or something like this
any case you can find it in the uh
in our
uh
listing on on youtube
it's it's a very clever thing he he
decided that he would he he had found a
uh
a loophole
um
and he could he could actually
uh
easily build the device at a relatively
low cost
which would uh
help the global warming situation
so
uh he did
he's in midst of doing this it's a it's
a very clever idea
uh he's um
he's burning methane
converting it to carbon dioxide
now it turns out methane is a much
better greenhouse glass gas than uh
than uh
carbon dioxide
uh it also doesn't last as long in the
atmosphere so methane is about a
oh
100 year persistence as opposed to a
thousand year persistence or something
like that for co2
and uh
most of the of the methane that's
produced
uh
and released into the air uh comes from
uh
shipping
it turns out
uh
we ignored
the uh
the landmasses
and
concentrated only on the uh water-based
systems the reason being that
water-based systems
controlled by the
law international law
and the land-based systems are
controlled by whoever happens to be
running the countries at the time
and it makes for much more difficult uh
you know
so basically he has a catalyst that's a
relatively inexpensive uh
iron salt that
if you put it in the
[Music]
smokestack
of a container ship
as an aerosol
it's hot goes up
in into the troposphere
part of the atmosphere that's dense and
close
and it will with with
using sunlight convert the
any methane that's flowing around into
carbon dioxide water
and uh
he
to sell his idea to people who were
watching what's going on he uh did some
simulations using uh
the
atmospheric modeling tools they're
readily available these days
and uh demonstrated that this
would probably cause
uh if applied for several
several years
uh drops of
up to a half a degree of centigrade
under the warning
and this whole thing could be done for a
reasonably small amount of time
now what reasonably small amounts of
money or something that has global
reaches is complicated but it's not that
it's not that fast
so it's interesting to see what uh what
he's doing
and
yet
i would have thought that the world
would have been beating a path to his
door
to try to uh
get this started and
be put out and used
as quickly as possible
that has not yet happened
[Music]
maybe next year
so
we have we have problems with the
society problems with sciences
um
we're
in the midst of the beginnings of
i don't know
what what's your
let's
belief
in world war three
no no no comments not even from the
audience out here if you're going to
write a comment
you think that we're uh at the beginning
of world war ii i i read the new york
times this morning and
it's like things were not uh
not stable in uh in the uk
and so we
we have this
this
proto-war that we're beginning to
look at
and that war is uh
is being fought in a somewhat different
way
and
that's that's really actually quite
interesting
uh
um
the
almost every country in the world has
decided that it's a bad idea to fight
for russia and ukraine to fight a war
and so that they have
been working to uh sort of
isolate
russia and the rest of the world
which turns out to be a very difficult
uh
difficult thing to do
um
paul vixie who's uh
an expert in the
internet uh
dns
uh did a study and showed that
taking the
dot ru
domain
out of the out of the out of the mix of
domains
was a uh
a very very difficult job
and in fact
he found out all sorts of interesting
things he didn't know
for example the dot r
uh
routing for lots of things went through
the ukraine
and the ukrainian stuff was russia
and uh
so it's it's it's an interesting problem
when you decide that what you want to do
is to isolate a particular country
economically and culturally
um
there are astronauts back from the
international space station uh on a
soyuz return vehicle just a couple weeks
ago
um
but
if
there was an all-out war um
it's not clear that that's
that's what's what happened
and then the
the russians are claiming
to
uh to bond with china
uh then uh
they will use uh
hypersonic
delivery vehicles and atomic weapons and
such like that if
they don't get their way in the ukraine
um
whether they will or not is an open
question and i don't know how we know
about that
another place that i think
you know
division is
possibly important
uh the uh
the
the economies of
economics
is uh is a fairly interesting thing to
take a look at
um
us u.s companies are
many of them have
operations
in
in russia
and uh it's a
it's a difficult uh thing to watch
what's what's going on um you know for
example um oracle
as a development center in saint
petersburg
always
order a thousand people
uh does uh
uh
oracle
system
construction and maintenance for uh
companies
throughout europe
and so has access to
uh lots of lots of the oracle uh
software and so forth
oracle's uh
does well in in russia
and
now they're
thinking of uh
having to uh
to close that down and to uh
to turn off uh
the work that's being done
but they have
of course many clients in uh
in russia
and the oracle
is very successful in what they do
and
you know it's not clear
what
level of
support oracle is going to need to
provide
to keep its customer base and russia
happy
uh in the midst of
the ongoing war
uh
presumably
uh
i don't know i it it depends a lot on
what contracts that oracle has with
russian entities
that are enforceable in russia
um
and you know we just i don't
have found nobody who's things you know
uh
but it's it's an interesting it's an
interesting issue because it
gets replicated uh
uh
a thousand times or more
uh in other places
in the uh
um
the
the
people who study the distribution of
food which they've said that
the ukrainian russian
war
is going to kill a number of people in
india
why because
ukraine is the
uh
supplies much of the uh
uh wheat that is uh
eaten in uh in india
and if
ukraine does not produce wheat
uh it's not clear that there's enough uh
support around
to actually do that
uh and to uh to support the needs of
india independent of whether there's
money
well
it's it it it's all very uh very
complicated
and
uh
but it requires
uh technical knowledge
of
in order to make reasonable decisions we
don't have uh
people who are
skilled
at doing a
evaluation
uh
that are available
we have you know our u.s government uh
intelligence people
uh
and we have
uh our
sort of rag ragtag
uncoordinated collection of people who
do analysis
for uh
and
none of those seem to have a great deal
of
impact on
on u.s policy
you know that's that's that's an issue
for me
um so this
just these sorts of these sorts of
things
um
have uh
have really been
a motivator for uh
for
for
essentially doing uh independent uh
research on what's what's going on and
you know by the way the
the uh the things i've said all come up
come from uh very reliable sources like
somebody on the internet uh some of
which is uh clearly going to be wrong
and uh
you know the
little
accuracy of
news articles that are published even
when they should be very very good is
not very high so
in addition to being confused by the
actual situations
we can be confused by people trying to
uh change our uh our uh
understanding of what's going on
uh typically you you know you like to
get one two or three or four sources
same thing
and
you oftentimes can get
multiple sources and the sources are
in contrast
for example
google
released
a version of the
google maps for russia
where russian military targets were not
uh
fuzzed
and this was uh this was
uh surprising for a number of people
and uh google said no we didn't do it
now we did a long time ago
uh
other people say well it just appeared
now and so forth
and so you have
many different stories about what the
situation is and it does not
always compute
another there's there's beginning to be
a community of uh
open source intelligence uh and their
analysts
who are
not attached to a uh
uh nation-states uh intelligence
organization but who do uh
analysis of data in various ways and
this
this is this is uh
uh what i was hoping i would be able to
have a speaker on
because i think i think it's very
interesting that we've reached a point
where
uh
the
level of
analysis that's needed to simply make
sense out of
the news that's in the various news
feeds
uh has gotten
to the point that you need
a separate independent and uh
welcoming organization
to do that
um
so
we're actually uh
moving right along here
uh the question is
what sort of things are you guys
interested in
i mean i i i'm interested in producing
uh essentially journalistic
level
analysis
accurate and
true of many of these these sorts of
things because i think i think that's
important for everybody to understand
um
yes
i'd like to participate for a second or
two please do
i'm sorry i just got here
uh i've known dennis for a while now
from when before covet when we had uh
face-to-face at uh stanford it was great
so nice to see you again dennis um
and uh
[Music]
the one i remember was michael b frank's
uh lecture uh i don't remember if you
were there but then we went and had a
chinese afterwards chinese dinner
together and talked about what mike was
doing
so
since that time i actually started a new
company called earth ict spc is earth
information communication technology
social purpose corporation for the
environment it's a california
new type of incorporation model and so
i'm working with
the
sky 130 which is a free
open
shuttle uh that uh skywater is running
and um
using that uh to
put together uh some adiabatic computing
uh projects
and the thing there is uh the un is
calling for the itc sector to uh hit 1.5
c by 2025 trajectory
and one way of doing that is of course
is to get alternative energy like sun or
wind uh
to power all the uh communications ict
sector stuff
the other way or a complimentary way is
to uh get energy efficiency and most of
the community doesn't understand that uh
you know the energy efficiency of
computers basically zero
um all the uh energy then comes out as
heat
so that's diabetic computing so part of
the
effort is to communicate uh
that there is an alternative way of
doing things
and uh go through all that anyway so so
i am just asking the community in terms
of participation i would love to i'm
working with uh
ng spikes on i'm right down there
working on a
circulatory uh
[Music]
high quality uh resonator uh power clock
and uh that's getting right down at it
and um
so if you got any uh
electrical uh analog energy uh engineers
out there mostly we find people who
understand quality factor in the rf area
you know the rf people
uh understand what quality factory is so
getting that into the clock and the uh
digital computer is uh
is uh something to be doing anyway
that's all i got and uh thank you very
much dennis it's great to see you again
and uh i love e uh three url will stick
you on i'll stick it up on the level
with the talk
thank you very much yeah i i in the
comments section or in the chat box i've
been sticking some things up but i will
send you some stuff thanks very much
dennis great thank you
so that's sort of where it is uh
you know
and you know so you have lots of little
people who are sort of
operating as small entities but we don't
have any collective
efforts
that's that's a problem
so
is is this the sort of thing that
interests you
it's always it's always the question
i if you wanted to uh
to spend time uh listening to talks
about uh
uh meta materials and uh
stuff at
atomic scale or uh
smaller
we can do that
um but i think the immediate impact is
a lot of these sort of semi-social
things
is uh is where
uh
where the uh
the problems really really long
um
we can make
really great ai chips
in fact there are
a dozen a dozen of them that are sort of
being described in the cylinder this
week
they're
they're amazing
and we get to build them
get
very small geometries and
they run very fast and they don't
they don't consume all that much power
anymore
we're going to have
interesting computing devices
in the next
well 20 years
you know problem there
the manufacturing
the fabs are not really
there aren't as many of them as we need
for what our
desires are
and
contrary to what
people have
in the news have been telling us
it takes a long time to make
that
you know the uh
three nanometer or uh two nanometer
nodes in a fab
uh take uh
lot of time to qualify
and so you may have building built
but you can't populate it with the
equipment you need for fabrication or
the
equipment has not had enough time that
the statistics are understood well
enough to get the yields up and
it's
it's going to be an interesting time
so anyhow i'd be really interested in
what your interests are
because i'm
i have i have some thoughts to fill
and i have choices to make
my ir that i'd like to
see some
some change in the way that
people
think about
science and
engineering i'd like to see
more mathematics
used
i'd like to see people understand that
modeling actually works
and
that
you have to be careful how you do it
it takes
some level of skill
to uh to do to do
systems modeling
but
it's
perfectly rational way to approach
things
and so
the people who uh try to denigrate the
uh
the
u.n climate reports
um
we haven't read
these are very convincing
and in fact
if anything you could argue that because
they take so long to produce
what they're reporting is ancient
history
um
beyonce you know you know that i i
pretty much have said my piece and uh
thank you for being my audience
you